How do you say this word: PECAN?
Fun fact, it’s the state nut of Alabama,
Arkansas, California, and Texas.
But is it puh-cawn, pee-cawn, pee-can,
or even puh-can? I don’t know anyone who says
that last one… Maybe you say it differently in
different contexts…butter puh-cawn ice cream,
pee-can pie… Well, you’re free to say what you
want, but we get the name for the nut, which
is native to North America, from the people
who are native to North America! Specifically
from those who speak Algonquin languages, of
which there are around 30.
In Kickapoo, the word for nut is pakaana,
in Menominee it’s pakān, in Ojibwemowin bagaan,
in Bodewadmimwen (Potawatomi) bgan or
pkan, and in Miami-Illinois pakaani.
And while people in the US have all sorts of
different pronunciations for those same five
letters, it seems like the closer you are
to the area where the trees natively grow,
the more likely you are to have
the source pronunciation: puh-cawn.
So the next time you’re crackin’ nuts
or sittin’ down to a nice slice of pie,
you might take a second to think
about where your words came from!